monty python you guys i believe started
making the show in 1968 16 69 in london
and
it was it took a while but it was it it
was and is revered over here as the gold
standard by everyone in comedy yet in
england you didn't know that for quite a
while oh no it took a very long time
every time i've ever done anything it's
taken a very long time for people to
decide
that they like it if they like it you
know um and i i think it's a real
originality and i've done two or three
really original things it takes time for
people to get used to it i think you
were saying in the break just now that
in the late 60s early 70s american
television was so safe and boring yes
yes and heavy yeah and i remember a guy
from uh what was it called wga gbh wgbs
boston
yeah and he came over and he said i hear
this is a very funny show
we're wondering if we could put it on
wgbh um can i watch a couple of episodes
with you and he sat in this darkened
room and watched the episodes and when
the lights went up he'd gone white
he said he'd seen a ghost yeah because
he was thinking what would happen to his
career if he ever put these shows up
right and so they nothing happened until
a guy called ron de villiers who was
running the pbs station in dallas
one day took a deep breath and said i'm
going to put a show out he put a monty
python out and all his pbs friends
called in
uh the next morning and said have they
burned the station down you know they
stone you on the way to the station this
morning and he said no problem and then
they all put it out and suddenly out it
came thank god about four months before
the holy grail came out
and that was why the holy grail was such
a a huge success because pbs had
prepared the way but also when you would
when you guys came i think you did a
hollywood bowl show when you came to
america for the first time when you did
your show everyone in the audience you
had no idea they were all saying the
lines to your sketches along with you it
was extraordinary i can still remember
it was opening night at city center in
new york and it must be 1976.
and i went on for the first sketch i did
the first line and there was hysterical
mindless cheering just like you get at
the beginning of every show right
[Applause]
not not because you don't deserve it no
no no i do not deserve it
uh they're actually they're from mildly
electrocuted yeah yeah yeah the seat the
seat has a prod it's a little mildly
electrocuted so this i did the first
line and the audience were mildly
electrocuted yes
and i then played the rest of the sketch
to complete silence
there's a big theater on an opening
night and i thought what the hell is
going on
and then i got to the end of the sketch
thinking what a terrible flop it had
been and again they were mildly
huge roar of applause and i went off and
i said to the stagehand
what the hell is going on he said you
don't understand this isn't a comedy
show it's a rock concert i said what are
you saying he said they know the lines
as well as you do they're just here to
be with you yes and they too he took me
and looked like we looked through a
little gauze window in the curtain so we
could see the audience they couldn't see
and they were they were like this
watching the next sketch
[Laughter]
they knew the lines
and when we did it at the o2 recently it
was embarrassing because they knew the
lines better than we did
yeah yeah they get you out of a pinch
every time uh i could talk to you for
about 40 days
all right we'd have food brought in
seriously uh this is it's such a delight
when you come on this program i i cannot
i cannot thank you enough or express
what this means to me so anyway
is available now and it is a must read
get this book or i will find you and i
will fight you john cleese
we will take a break